[Music]
let's say there's a disaster that sends
humanity back to the Stone Age can our
knowledge and history survive the
printed page will decompose hard drive
storage will deteriorate even stones
will eventually crumble but we might
have something inside us that can
outlast these physical limitations
deoxyribonucleic acid DNA already stores
our biological information from eye
color to skin tone it programs our
entire body's DNA is made of four
organic bases adenine guanine cytosine
and thymine or a G C and T the specific
sequence of these bases into groups of
three known as codons gives our cells
instructions to make each of the
proteins in our bodies but this code can
be used for other things too like secret
messages in 1999 scientists in New York
created an alphabet in which each of the
64 possible DNA codons substituted for a
specific letter number or grammar symbol
they spliced a 22 character message into
a long strand of DNA and surrounded it
with specific genetic markers they then
hid the DNA over a period in a
typewritten letter with only a small
smudge to give the location away they
mailed the letter back to themselves
then they examined the letter looking
for the DNA strand once the DNA strand
was located
they found the genetic markers then they
sequenced the DNA and successfully
decoded the message it soon became
obvious that DNA cryptography could code
for much more than simple text by
translating the ones and zeros of binary
code into DNA codons digital data could
be programmed into synthetic DNA then
decoded back into its original form in
2012 UK scientists encoded 739 kilobytes
of computer files into DNA strands
including all 150
for Shakespeare's sonnets and an excerpt
from Martin Luther King's I have a dream
speech and four years later researchers
at Microsoft and the University of
Washington broke that record
they used binary coding to capture a
whopping 200 megabytes of data including
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights and a high def Ok Go music video
all in strings of DNA as far as storage
capacity goes DNA stands out because of
the surprising amount of information it
can hold in so little space
the current theoretical limit of DNA's
storage capacity is so high that you
could fit 100 million HD movies on a
pencil eraser it's even conceivable that
one day we could fit all of the
information currently on the internet
into the space of a shoebox also
computers and the magnetic tape and
disks that their information is stored
on them only lasts for a few decades at
most before degrading and becoming
unreliable meanwhile DNA has a half-life
of 500 years meaning that's how long it
takes for half of its bonds to break and
if left in a cold and dark environment
DNA could potentially last for hundreds
of thousands of years and if that isn't
long enough scientists experimented with
having synthetic DNA Auto reproduce
after creating their own strands of DNA
that spelled out the lyrics to the
children's song it's a small world they
place them into the genome of a microbe
nicknamed cone and the bacterium Conan
belongs to a species which can survive
in a vacuum or without water for six
years or come out unscathed after being
exposed to a dose of radiation 1,000
times that which would kill a human
according to the experiment the
bacterium was able to reproduce at least
100 generations without data loss
theoretically if the organism had
redundant copies of the information that
could be used to autumn
matically correct mistakes the
information could stay preserved even
longer so one day you might be able to
create a living growing knowledge
archive in your own backyard and it's
seeds might carry your family's history
a detailed breakdown of the world's
political upheavals or the some of
humanity's knowledge into forests and
across continents perhaps even into the
far reaches of space though we might one
day disappear
perhaps our legacy can still live on if
anyone would think to find it did you
enjoy this lesson if so please consider
supporting our nonprofit mission by
visiting patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]